let's just get this over with everyone
knows Spectacular Spider-Man was a great
show it was accurate to the source
material it had a great voice cast that
really fit the characters and it told
its stories with planned out long-term
arcs in mind that always had a payoff or
would have led to something greater it
was pretty much the complete package and
Sony did a good job with it while it was
still running the television rights to
Spider-Man were returned to Marvel by
Sony in September 2009 as a concession
for holding on to the movie rights for
ever but Disney purchased Marvel in
December 2009 and with that deal they
actually also purchased the TV rights to
Spider-Man which meant that Sony and
Marvel both no longer had the rights to
keep the show going Disney did
ultimately ugh they couldn't continue it
because Sony still had the rights to
spectacular and had to start fresh with
something created in-house that they
could manage and work on on their own
instead of having to cooperate with guys
like Victor cook and Greg Weisman that
already had their own intentions for a
spidey show this all it gets a new
series titled after and Loosely adapting
Brian Michael Bendis and Mark bagley's
Ultimate Spider-Man comics you can tell
because of that haircut no one has
anymore
it was big in the late 90s early 2000s
though when comparing this to the comics
I think it's most fair to base that
comparison on the 1610 books since
that's what the ultimate series was
using for a baseline though I wish we
got something a little bit more similar
to the tone and storylines of that book
because for all its faults still really
interesting and likable comic I know
everyone had words for Ultimate
Spider-Man when it came out thinking it
was the worst things could possibly get
they're wrong but between the childish
sense of humor that often Falls flat for
viewers over the age of say six the lack
of depth to the characters and
storytelling or the really poor voice
acting from certain major characters
there's a lot of valid reasons to hate
this show and I will be talking about a
lot of them however I think we're all
too harsh on Ultimate I mean it's not
perfect by a long shot but it's not
completely irredeemable
some stuff I like here there's some
things I may not agree with but I
understand them
I do find some of its stranger quirks at
least fascinating to talk about and
dissect probably one of the biggest
sources of frustration is that there's
four times as much of this series as
spectacular and a huge portion of that
can be sort of low quality but
nonetheless this is the longest running
Spider-Man series by far there's a lot
here but a big fear of doing this video
is that it would just be 100 complaining
and trashing a show that's been trashed
to death already so let's be fair to it
and acknowledge its merits while also
not straying away from talking about
what it lacked
here's a lukewarm defense of Ultimate
Spider-Man
I guess I don't know I ended up really
wanting it to be over the more I watched
it we could be a team we gonna get fame
money don't forget the [ __ ] there's
not gonna be Fame and there's not gonna
be [ __ ]
okay I didn't ask for any of this I just
want to be like everybody else
[Laughter]
[Music]
this series differs from the Rest by
firmly planting itself in a Marvel
universe that is currently inhabited by
hundreds have already established heroes
and villains instead of Spidey keeping
pretty much to himself minus the
occasional crossover the show begins
with him getting roped into a special
team of upcoming teenage superheroes
sponsored by shield and Nick Fury with
the goal of improving his independent
superhero gig into a government-funded
and trained Ultimate Spider-Man because
of his on-the-job superhero experience
Spidey is placed as the leader of this
team and finds himself responsible for
guiding and training Luke Cage Iron Fist
Tigra and Nova given that Luke Cage ends
up marrying someone that was in Peter's
High School class I always figured that
they weren't that far apart in age but
squarely placing Luke Cage as well as
his best bud Iron Fist as teenagers the
same age as Spider-Man
feels a little weird to me those two
being here immediately discounts any
chance of continuity with Avengers
Earth's Mightiest Heroes so let's
consider this a fresh start of an
entirely new Marvel animated universe I
guess that makes this like the fourth
one now
I'll start by saying I do like the look
of this show the character designs are
Pleasant detailed colorful and distinct
for this particular take without being
too stylized there's a loose attempt to
pay tribute to Mark bagley's ultimate
interpretations the characters which is
more prevalent in some characters than
others I've always thought his vision
for the Spider-Man world was really cool
looking and modern without betraying the
classic character designs or being
overly militarized and that translated
well into the visual style of this
series I think it looks even better in
season 2 when they start drawing Peter
with a more square jaw and making his
Spider-Man eyes even more wildly emotive
and expressive gets you a man that could
go from Eric Larson to Gabrielle delado
at a moment's notice I'm fine thanks for
asking anyway
[Music]
actually is the show's art style change
I feel like he started looking mostly
like John Byrne Spider-Man later on and
you know this show isn't lacking for
solid action when it comes down to the
fight scenes they're well choreographed
and well animated a lot of the
techniques here with combining 2D
characters in 3D moving backgrounds are
like a massive evolution of what they
really wanted to do with the 90s series
just with new technology that can make
it look really cool it's all just
integrated a little bit better than it
used to be
the battles between Spidey and his
villains are always exciting and fun to
watch and the fact that he's usually
backed up by a whole team of other
superheroes in these fights adds for
some variety that other Spidey shows
never really add say for maybe amazing
friends since they're usually not this
heavy with Crossovers and these
crossovers with other heroes are usually
the best part of this show the way
Spidey interacts with every avenger or
random hero that pops in is totally
different the Fanboys over Iron Man Has
immense respect for Captain America he
thinks Moon Knight is a weirdo he has a
friendly rivalry with Hawkeye he can't
stand Wolverine and he always Advocates
that the Hulk is a good guy that's just
misunderstood and you just know I gotta
talk about the Deadpool episode this was
Deadpool's first time being allowed to
directly interact with a cartoon
Spider-Man after those two other times
where we got blue balled but I'm very
indifferent to this episode in terms of
riding a Deadpool for kids it's fine I
guess I like that it's adapting issue 2
of Deadpool's first off ongoing series
by Joe Kelly one of the founders of Man
of Action I gotta wonder if he had a
direct role in this episode using that
influence for the plot never heard of
you I designed this costume myself black
and white eyes red suit so you made it
your own with the crossword theme oh
wait webs those are webs wilfredle could
be a great Deadpool if he gave the voice
a little bit more Terry McGinnis and
less raw Unstoppable you attacked me
with puns puns and bullets and pointy
things yes I can I'm running the show
now and this is just the tip of the
spear although overall for a voice for
Deadpool on this I would have preferred
Nola North or Jason spysik since he was
really good in the Marvel anime stuff go
check out my video on those all this
show is sorely missing for crossovers is
a proper Fantastic Four Episode we only
get the thing one time all of these team
ups we do get are pretty cool and if
this show is going to be so full of
crossover as they might as well be the
best part of it however these developed
in unique interactions ironically don't
carry over for Spidey in the main cast
of Heroes that are in pretty much every
episode despite by being around nearly
all the time in the first few seasons
Shield superhero Teen team are oddly
underdeveloped and lacking in any deep
connection with Spidey or even each
other the team's Dynamic is also never
fully formed these characters don't
bounce off of each other well or really
at all you'd expect Luke Cage and Danny
Rand to be growing out all over the
place but they barely speak to each
other none of these characters really
talk to each other in a scene without
Spider-Man present we as the viewer
never get a sense of any relationships
between them at all
the only real thing they share is
constantly ganging up on Peter and
treating him as an outlier
all of their interpersonal conflicts
turn into him versus them no one ever
seems to side with him when there's an
argument among the team and they always
act like they don't like him that much
you seen my friend Peter shrimpy kid
spaghetti arms three dollar haircut only
a 98 average Nova and white tiger in
particular are especially rude to him
you ever meet someone who makes [ __ ]
uncomfortable by getting way too chummy
and personal way too fast with friendly
insults I'm coming
tell me you got that Nova totally got it
Power Man best friends can poke fun at
each other and make snarky comments
because it's earned and comes from a
place of love
the team are all [ __ ] on Spidey the
second they meet him and the level of
respect and courtesy never really forms
I mean maybe in the last episode as like
a just like a we gotta wrap things up
but ugh they're always hostile or
putting him in a bad spot by being
selfish [ __ ]
that's why you ditched me so you could
come home and throw a party
um surprise
we are not having a party it's called
squash the spider
[Music]
friends like seeds who needs enemies so
we don't buy this [ __ ] we're a
family rhetoric because he never truly
feels like one of them no matter how
nice he is to them it never seems to be
enough if your family treats you like
this then just get a new one [ __ ] those
guys and these characters are not
strongly developed enough on their own
to make up for this Behavior you don't
get a sense of why they're so snotty
they're just like that and it never
becomes endearing doing a show like this
with an emphasis on a team you want to
Spotlight each character's importance to
the team's Dynamic their backstory and
what makes them unique incredibly early
or the viewer isn't going to care about
them but the shield kids don't get
individual episodes to flesh them out
until Midway through season two and
these attempts to build them up are
pretty laughable the best try was with
white tiger because now we know that she
inherited her powers from her dad who
was killed by Craven the hunter she's
always fighting back a lot of rage just
like your your father and your
grandfather before you you use your
powers of the white tiger for good like
you did when you took down crave that
white tiger is still inside you yeah
that's all well and good but all we
really get about Luke and Iron Fist are
reasons they've gotten powers and not
much else in terms of Personality Spidey
finds out that Luke thought his parents
were killed by terrorists trying to
steal their super soldier serum but it
turns out they're not and they're fine
they go save them together and that's
all we get no deeper insights into
Luke's mentality as a hero or what makes
him who he is or any kind of
philosophical stuff about him it's just
it's all treated so casually and surface
level you risked Your Life For Me When
We rescued your parents you didn't think
you just did
Iron Fist is sidelined through most of
his episode to focus on Spidey having a
battle with scorpion
who is a ninja and sounds like Zuko in
this universe I guess the only thing
Spidey learns about Iron Fist in this
episode is that he has a lot of money he
never spends
faster from kunlun Remember The Xiao Lau
the trials we Face together friend is no
more and Nova Jesus Christ they didn't
even [ __ ] try with Nova his entire
episode is more about propping up the
Guardians of the Galaxy like a big
advertisement and he's hardly there for
it season two ends with Green Goblin
mind controlling the team and turning
them into goblins and Peter attempts to
get through to them by reminding them of
all these events and their bond and he
has like nothing to say to Nova at all
like the friends we are we saved an
entire galaxy Sam we can beat one silly
Goblin
come to think of it Nova in the show is
an irredeemable annoying piece of human
garbage yeah you get a job now Parker
you don't need to kiss up to money bags
anymore for cash
costume
and Sam wanted to see the look on your
face right there that Priceless I'm 100
certain that Sam Alexander is a pretty
cool character in the comics and doesn't
act anything close to this irritating on
his worst day it seems like they wanted
him to be like a lovable [ __ ] but
forgot the lovable part every single
line of dialogue out of his mouth is
talking about how great he thinks he is
or trying to take someone else down a
peg usually Spider-Man there was a point
where they made it seem like he was
going to be written out of the show and
I was so excited until it turned out to
be a fake out
[ __ ] this guy seriously eventually these
guys stop being front and center so all
the time wasted with them is even more
frustrating in the later half of the
show they fade into the background as
Spidey starts going to Shield Academy
for training superheroes they're not
really his close circle of friends
anymore they're just kids he goes to
school with among like a dozen others
that kept getting added as the show went
on they pretty much just got replaced
with a team of spider themed characters
for the whole web warriors thing given
the involvement of pauldini in this
coming out around the same time as
Batman the Brave and the Bold I always
assume this was supposed to be like that
but for Spider-Man
a more lighthearted and campy show with
a sense of humor that's willing to play
around with the absurdity of comics and
their characters
Batman is basically never Bruce Wayne in
that show because he's too busy having
Adventures
Braven the Bold is also entirely focused
on crossovers with DC characters outside
of the Batman world and showcasing
weirder and more amusing parts of comic
history to kids that they wouldn't
really know about this was going for
something similar this isn't the show
where Gwen Stacy dies in a PG-13 movie
spin-off or Peter visits a little girl
with cancer this is a show where Loki
turns Spidey into spider ham or the Team
battles awesome Android or they give
Sandman that silly costume from the
comics or Spider-Man goes to Boston
because New Yorkers treat him like crap
actually on the list of recommendations
for episodes of the show I put
Spider-man on the very top that episode
is so weird and funny and irreverent
it's like the one time I think they
nailed what kind of humor they were
going for because otherwise totally not
handled
who are you talking to
come out I'll go sunlight all over you
humor in this show drags it down
immensely
okay okay turns out he's pretty cool
live and learn huh
this [ __ ] thinks he's She-Hulk you wish
buddy so yes Batman the Brave and the
Bold is silly and intentionally funny
this show this just makes you Big Man on
Campus
[Music]
is trying to also be that prevailing
miserably Spider-Man's fourth wall
breaking shtick was such a misfire and
it hurts this show so much because it
didn't work one time
and it's in like almost every episode
at best it's like a Family Guy style
cutaway gag that doesn't quite land at
worst it's like if you're reading a
comic book and some annoying [ __ ] who
thinks he's way funnier than he actually
is walks into the room takes it out of
your hands and explains to you exactly
what you just read then he hands it back
to you and leaves and then at the bottom
of the next page he comes back again hey
remember that visual gag and Spectacular
Spider-Man where Flash Thompson agreed
to be Nick bottom in the school play not
knowing that character gets magically
turned into a literal jackass okay so
imagine a billion jokes like that but
without the clever parts
boy do I feel like a
[Music]
little cheap y tiny Spider-Man shows up
and just says the most unfunny [ __ ] this
Show's sense of humor is like every
generic joke people say when they want
to exaggerate that something is failing
at comedy
but completely unironic
awkward
what are you all looking at
there's something behind me isn't there
he's right behind me isn't he
so that happened at a certain point I
have to wonder who is this show for
because the writing is so aggressive
about holding your hand and over
explaining to you everything that's
happening it makes me wonder if this was
meant to be aimed at way younger kids
Spider-Man is either pausing the scene
to deliver clumsy Exposition directly to
the viewer in case they missed a
previous episode or sometimes just
explain to you what you just saw five
seconds ago as if you like you're a
small child that didn't quite get it
this monkey sound effect is to this show
as the whip crack is the Johnny Test God
damn
what if I just put that in the other
Spider-Man [ __ ]
look over the side hero we have a
surprise for you
I'm not sure why so few of the writers
could make the fourth wall humor
actually convey useful information or at
the very least a little more amusing
than like a light chuckle every eighth
joke
I don't think Disney wanted this show to
fail they got a lot of talent in the
writer's room pauldini co-creator of
Batman the Animated Series was a
consultant writer on this man of action
the creative team that made Ben 10 and
Generator Rex both solid shows were
there too Brian Michael Bendis love him
or hate him had some compelling stories
about Spidey in the short term so having
him pen a few episodes wasn't
necessarily doomed to fail plus he wrote
some of the best stuff in the 2003 show
so why not and yet we get an adaptation
of the Ultimate Comics Arc where
Spider-Man and Wolverine switch brains
and he still made it a point to have
Wolverine flirt with a 15 year old Mary
Jane baby I do like me a redhead
foreign
why why keep that
dumbass so much of the writing in the
show is really weak characters aren't
developed at all plots don't really go
anywhere and sometimes I swear it feels
like characters are just saying dialogue
for the sake of saying dialogue even if
the thing they said doesn't really make
any sense in context of what's happening
or what was said just a second ago
what's wrong aren't you going to run
away yeah cool story bro that wasn't a
story Amadeus he asked you a question
how can he be so happy I'm never that
happy I'm Spider-Man
whips or jokes where's your sense of
humor Peter he made a joke like 10
seconds ago what the hell are you
talking about Norman
and who's coming to hit me again
maybe on a script level these lines
might work like if you're reading it and
the voice director is just asleep at the
wheel and letting them read the lines in
a way that doesn't really make sense
hey new recording session I don't have a
throat infection anymore so now my voice
sounds okay the show never grew on me
per se but I did start to enjoy watching
it more in the later Seasons because the
most annoying Parts became less
prevalent and more interesting Side
characters started to take Center Stage
like miles and Scarlet Spider I don't
think Ultimate Spider-Man ever really
found its footing but later on it got
closer at least while the heroes
struggles characters for various reasons
I am fascinated by what this show does
with a lot of its villains some of the
long-running story arcs of the show give
special attention to Norman Osborne
becoming an ultimate in 616 Goblin
hybrid
Doc Ock repeatedly leading the Sinister
Six and both of them using Venom as a
sort of Bio weapon much like the actual
Ultimate Universe the Symbiote isn't an
alien but a synthetic creature created
in a lab This Time by Otto instead of
Peter and Eddie's dads Venom isn't
really a character in this universe so
much as it is a plot device there's no
Eddie Brock so Harry Osborne is the
original villainous host for the
Symbiote and I don't really like that
direction
harder I want to prove myself
I'm riding the world of you hearing
Venom refer to Green Goblin as father
bothers me I don't like those characters
being so tight at the hip they're both
unique antagonists on their own Carnage
appears in season two but is basically
just Venom again but slightly upgraded
and the host is Peter hearkening back to
the PS2 game shoe warning him in because
of Venom Carnage boss fight was pretty
cool I have a score to settle
because we have a score to settle kind
of giving me mixed signals Venom then
they bring Carnage back in season four
and he's totally different they act like
it's his first time ever showing up
again there's no Cletus Cassidy because
uh
it's hard to have a Disney animated show
with a serial killer at least his voice
and design are better the second time
around
eventually Venom finds a new host in
season three with Flash Thompson and I
don't really love that either because
it's too early flash needs a lot of
growth and humbling before that works
this is a show for children so they
can't show him losing his legs in
unspecified the war and I suspect they
only included him in this show because a
it was current in the books at the time
and B Because the show was retitled to
web Warriors and I think they wanted
more spider themed characters for the
new toy line that assuredly resulted I
guess it's all right though because no
Spider-Man show has ever ever ever going
to last long enough to fully adapt all
the flashtops and stuff accurately so
it's either shove Agent Venom in too
early or he'll just never appear in any
animated form at all 20 years later and
morbius still can't drink blood in these
shows
[Music]
I can now dream the life energy from any
being Norman Osborne is played more
sympathetically this time around than
the previous show and I like that choice
him being the goblin is a change that's
forced upon Him by Doc Ock and not
something he personally desired but when
he's cured of goblinism he's actually a
pretty alright guy and makes legitimate
attempts to help Peter or become a
superhero himself as Iron Patriot and
it's not all a big trick like in dark
Reign he's actually doing the right
thing I also love how Electro is voiced
by former Spidey Christopher Daniel
Barnes once again Electro in the comics
has no personality so they can just do
whatever with him in this universe he's
the only villain that actually enjoys
spidey's banter and finds his jokes
pretty funny always have your team in
attendance
anyone have a pencil so I can scribble
that one down
upstairs does it take to change a light
bulb
sitch on One display
you guys want to see that it actually
does work maybe later sort of a
cross-generational spidey supporting
Spidey thing also for everyone that
commented on the last episode and said
that Electro is interesting because he
was a normal working class guy before
his villain days and he's like Peter if
he was given great Powers but wasn't
responsible with it
you know that applies to like 40 other
characters in these Comics too right try
harder I want you to dig deep prove me
wrong give me a real legitimate reason
to think Electro doesn't totally suck
compared to every other villain in
Spider-Man please like try hard and
speaking of those other villains they
kind of get the shaft in this show Rhino
is a mutated teenager at Peter's school
trying to get back at Flash Thompson and
the episode is like a big anti-bullying
message but not nearly as impactful or
dark as that other show eventually he's
recruited by Shield to help Spider-Man
so he
it stops being a villain vulture is a
teenage goth kid with amnesia and sort
of like a fusion of vulture and carrion
of all characters the fact that he looks
so much like this Show's version of Otto
Octavius and has the same voice actor
Tom Kenny really made me think that they
were going to reveal he was some kind of
Doc Ock clone at some point but that
never happened so he just looks and
sounds like Doc Ock for no reason
scorpion is a rival ninja from kunlun
that hates Iron Fist
Mysterio made a deal with dormammu to
create actual magic instead of Illusions
but he ends up reforming to take care of
his teenage daughter all of these are
very strange and feel like changes made
just for the sake of being different not
for doing something more interesting
with the characters I suspect some of
these wildly alternate takes were
mandated by Disney as a way to
differentiate this series from
spectacular Spider-Man since these came
out so close together
I could never find a source to fact
check this but I read online once at
some point in the last decade that this
Show's mission statement was not to
retread the same ground as spectacular
which is why there's no Eddie Brock no
real Peter Parker home life drama and
why so many of the villains are heavily
remixed like you got this show that was
really good and comic accurate and was a
hit with fans and critics alike and will
be remembered and loved forever for its
really brilliant stamp on the character
and now you have to do the exact
opposite of what that did
which if you think about it sort of set
them up for failure I've never been able
to find a source to corroborate this but
I think it would explain a lot of things
about this show that never really gelled
with Spidey fans it's a multiversal
constant that Flash Thompson will wear
this costume at some point be mistaken
for the real Spider-Man by a villain
I hope to see this trend continue it's
really awesome you may be wondering in
the wake of spectacular Spider-Man
making an interesting and well-developed
character out of everyone Peter went to
school with how does Ultimate Spider-Man
handle his massive cast of Side
characters
unfortunately extremely poorly everyone
has one personality trait Mary Jane
wants to be a reporter because they keep
making her Lois Lane we know nothing
else about her and she's basically
irrelevant to this entire series you
could cut her out entirely and it
wouldn't change a thing they gave her
the Carnage symbiote and made her Spider
Woman in the last season so that
character had something to do after not
appearing for like 30 straight episodes
but even that episode is more about
Scarlet Spider than her so it wasn't
necessary she just doesn't do anything
important in the entire cartoon and her
and Peter are also strictly friends and
never actually attempt any sort of
relationship this Spider-Man is
bitchless by choice they didn't even
want to try to write any kind of romance
plot because it would be too clumsy and
difficult this Spider-Man is Arrow Ace I
guess Peter and Flash's bully and victim
to friends Arc is Clumsy rushed and
doesn't hit as hard as the prior version
but an attempt was made at the very
least but much like MJ it seems like the
writers were constantly shoving Harry
into new costumes and personas because
they didn't know what else to do with
him so he's black suit Spider-Man Venom
the Patriot instead of American son an
anti-venom in this show none of which
were really all that interesting at all
which is why it kept changing so often
they found something that worked it
would have stuck but he's just ugh it
seems like the writers of the show were
afraid to tackle any kind of character
drama that resembled real life so it was
easier to just slap stupid random
superpowers on everyone and call it a
day it gets very repetitive that
everyone Peter goes to high school with
ends up becoming a superhero at some
point this shows Aunt May's decent at
least and this is the first animated
version of her to learn Peter's secret
so it's kind of cool to see her being
like an active parent to a superhero
the Peter Parker element of this show
goes out the window for long stretches
you can go multiple full episodes back
to back without him taking his mask off
at all he starts living at the shield
facility full time and has no school
career social life or a job they don't
explain why Aunt May doesn't even notice
him leaving the house and living
somewhere else The Duality of Spider-Man
is a real non-entity for most of this
show Ultimate Spider-Man also has some
very repetitive storytelling choices
that unintentionally highlight the other
biggest issue with this show several
times
several they do a Freaky Friday body
swap story where Spider-Man and another
major Marvel characters switch mines or
switch bodies whatever
you put your mind in Spider-Man's body
they're brilliant oh I'm going to write
that down and in these moments we hear
really talented voice actors like Steve
Bloom Fred tattershore and Troy Baker
all technically play Peter Parker in
someone else's body we switched bodies
we switched to tired bodies what did you
do what freaky things you do to me that
I'm in your hairy beast buddy oh come on
my brain is in the Hulk's body this
cannot be happening again oh my life is
ruined finally if anyone could tell I'm
not the real Loki it'd be you right
cool Loki doesn't fly I thought looky
flew we gotta get to him somehow well
Drake Bell plays
uh attempts to play these other
characters you lost him you don't lose
him he's a Tracker like me he's on your
Trail you dumb kid no I'm telling you I
totally it's me fool I promised you
Spider-Man's body here it is
[Laughter]
Hulk like purple oh man they really hate
the Hulk and I thought they hated me
leave hook body alone hearing this
juxtaposition of the way more
experienced veteran voice actors against
Belle's feigned and half-hearted
attempts to be these other guys paints a
giant arrow pointing at the ultimate
Spider-Man's most glaring design flaw
I hope I don't miss one it would hurt a
lot go
Drake Bell isn't a very good voice actor
like at all
is it weird that your voice is like
claws on a chalkboard I mean sure I
loved him and Drake and Josh growing up
I think he'd be hard-pressed to find an
American in their early 20s that doesn't
have a very fond memory of that show but
acting in a TV sitcom is extremely
different from voice acting Drake's
delivery is pretty much always the same
exaggerated High projection for a studio
audience not very believable but you
still buy it anyway because the fake
sets in high key lighting waiting for
the laugh tracks sort of acting and it
just doesn't work here I know it was a
Nickelodeon show but it's still
basically Disney Channel acting he can
very rarely deliver any believable
intensity how's your Aunt May Peter she
seems like a nice woman leave her alone
God stay away from her you hear me you
monster
die monster his line reads remind me of
someone doing a comical
over-enthusiastic Sonic the Hedgehog
impression where the punchline is the
voice itself and not anything they said
in the voice before this his only voice
acting credits were extras and Rugrats
episodes or The Nutty Professor animated
movie what do you do
[Music]
on second thought sit chunky you're not
my type
uh yeah let's give this guy the lead in
our animated series with 104 episodes he
was team guy number three and all grown
up so you know
big Talent we have scripts with
generally grading and unfunny jokes as
read by a voice actor that can't really
make any of it sound natural or
believable and it just kind of makes
Spider-Man immensely annoying instead of
charismatic or likable like you just
kind of want him to shut the hell up
already the villains should be feeling
that about him not me the audience I
should be thinking he's funny what if I
told you that this is myself that every
day I work so hard to be disciplined a
student Ava and resist my true instincts
well I'm done
stunt casting major roles in the series
with untrained voices that were in tween
sitcoms at the time you say why not
throw two more on that pile white
Tiger's voice had one credit on IMDb
before this Nova's VA also has the same
credit who the hell even heard of this
I'm in the Band show I never watched it
was it any good are these two good in
that show at least please for the love
of God higher voice actors to voice Act
there are already so many Josh Keaton's
Ben diskens James Arnold Taylor's Robbie
Damon's and Yuri lowenthals all lined up
to be Spidey in this the decision to go
with Drake Bell is so baffling to me
because clearly he didn't win the role
with his talent it was their hopes that
the tweens would recognize his name from
that other show and get excited
are you sure you're not confusing two
completely different Target audiences is
one in the same and to make matters
worse they have their very own
spider-verse event where we get to hear
several voice actors take on the same
role and you just wish the show had been
about one of them this whole time except
for not made a spider girl she stinks
Christopher Daniel Barnes is killing it
though back lest I be forced to hurt me
by Merlin either Thou Art training to be
my Squire although at the Town four in
every Universe Peter Parker stands for
heroism and responsibility except for
one
no hell is blood spider and even
spider-ham Ben diskin is killing it may
I
scientific curiosity if I could create
my own sunlight I could eliminate the
vampire's Reign once and for all with
this
what are you doing here looking for a
bathroom what do you think I'm doing
here I'm here to help now hurry up Ben
diskin honestly would have been a great
pick to voice Spider-Man in this whole
show he's in the same sort of vocal
ballpark they were aiming for but with
way more talent and experience and oh
man I'd kill for Spider-Man 2099 cartoon
or anything with this voice actor again
it's just so obvious and distracting
who's played by an actual voice actor
and who is just a sitcom star they
pulled into the booth to lazily read
lines while looking at their phones and
waiting for an easy paycheck even in the
episodes where they have him singing he
doesn't sound that good I will save you
all by crawling up your wall I'm
Spider-Man and I spider Ram I am
Spider-Man
how's that even possible is he singing
not as well on purpose so it doesn't
seem like Peter has a really great
singing voice
I'm giving him too much credit I just
don't think he cared that much and it
doesn't get better after 104 episodes
his quality of voice acting stays the
same the entire way through anything fun
always ends with something exploding too
late Spider-Man
weed has been legalized what how come
Spidey never mentioned a spider ham that
he was also a pig once in an earlier
season oh because these episodes were
written by totally different people and
there was no coordination in the
writer's room at all why has Spider-Man
made it a personal mission to fight
every member of the cast of Wings
regardless this shows two spider-verse
arcs are some of the highlights for
heavily featuring Christopher Daniel
Barnes in multiple roles and doing some
really decent miles and Peter stuff I
feel like some elements of these
episodes ended up being inspiration for
the spider-verse movie like that
alternate universe Goblin design the
fact that Donald Glover got to play
Miles Morales and Aaron Davis before
anyone else is really cool to me
considering he was the inspiration for
this storyline in the first place
your city belongs to the Grand Master no
can't be How It Ends
if this were any other Spider-Man show
the whole thing would have ended right
here this is the only one that didn't
get canceled on a cliffhanger after four
seasons every character acts almost
exactly the same as they did in season
one except Flash Thompson somehow he's
the only character that had any
development that mattered or affected
anything and even then him discovering
Peter's identity is brushed off so
quickly puny Parker
yeah but no no no no no no no that's
impossible this wasn't the game changer
I was expecting what did you not feel
like crying I would have made that a
bigger deal than one line of dialogue
and then instant acceptance for the
whole rest of the show
oh
[Music]
you're in the end of this series I was
starting to get exhausted with it but
kept hanging on because I at least like
Agent Venom Miles Morales and Scarlet
Spider it's kind of an issue when those
three are more exciting to watch than
the actual Ultimate Spider-Man [ __ ]
changing miles is named a kid or acne
though that was just disrespectful you
can't both be Spider-Man kid arachnid
that's not
not bad actually do I look like a kid
arachnid to you I guess so I don't care
if it's confusing just call him
Spider-Man [ __ ] I went into this show
and this review really wanting to defend
it and assure you that it's over hated
but
watching the entire thing back to back
really showed me that a lot of the
complaints back in the day were totally
valid despite the strong animation
Aesthetics character designs it's a
mildly interesting alterations to the
Spider-Man Mythos can't say overall that
I actually like this show all these nice
things are so heavily overshadowed by
its flaws and I can't say I'd ever find
myself wanting to re-watch it after this
review I don't think I'd ever just like
casually turn it on and relive it the
writing is surface level the characters
are flat the humor is completely
irritating and every interesting idea is
muddled by the above I don't hate it
but it doesn't hold a ton of value in my
eyes and I can't really muster the
strength to say it's underrated or any
of that [ __ ] I think maybe we
overreacted and hated it too much but
every complaint about it was pretty much
on the money too that's why I said this
defense was really lukewarm where it's
like yeah you guys are right but I don't
know I don't hate it that much there's
stuff that's cool
I like Scott Porter I can't think of
much that this show did that had a
lasting influence on the character or
the fans in the same way its
predecessors did other Spidey cartoons
were used as the blueprint for multiple
whole movies introduced ideas that were
cool enough to pull into the books or
are just so fascinating that they're
being talked about decades after they
ended Ultimate Spider-Man was perhaps a
trial run for the MCU Spider-Man by
having him so heavily connected with
other Marvel characters and even meeting
MCU specific characters like these three
[ __ ] from Agents of Shield but even
that end result was so extremely
different from this and I feel like the
MCU Spidey ended up taking more from
spectacular and frankly I just never see
or hear anyone talk about this show
anymore it's the longest running Marvel
cartoon ever by a wide margin and yet it
just seems like it came and went and
that was it maybe a few ideas from it
weirdly ended up in the Insomniac games
but like feel like no one even really
noticed that after four seasons of 104
episodes the show was canceled and very
swiftly rebooted I assume in no small
part due to Drake Bell getting a DUI the
first in a long stream of very
questionable actions from the singer and
Disney probably felt it better for their
brand to start over once again without
his name attached which is fine because
after four seasons it had run its course
if you don't get anywhere after 104
episodes
you're really not going to get anywhere
after that Ultimate Spider-Man struggled
in a lot of ways but had untapped
potential and opportunities to improve
slightly that it never fully grasped
it'll never have the same lasting impact
in high regard of these other shows
because it went for quantity over
quality and always held itself back from
more interesting things with its
characters it just goes to show that a
series that took the easy route at every
turn really didn't end up challenging
its audience in any way that made them
care it lacked a lot to be desired but
you know
could always be worse
and you have a cut on your lip
uh
uh my crack pipe broke you have a
scratch on your neck yes I
met a girl on Craigslist and you have a
bruise on your neck
I met a guy on Craigslist
[Music]
thank you
[Music]